une venue très médiatique au centre
hospitalier de versailles à l'occasion
du lancement de l'opération pièces
jaunes opération qui permet d'apporter
un soutien financier à l'amélioration
des services pédiatriques dans les
hôpitaux de france par la neige chirac
en porte parole emblématique christian
karembeu et clément lefert en parent à
la fondation pedn a décidé cette année
de faire pas mal de projets sportifs
dans les hôpitaux pour aider à la
réinsertion de ces jeunes est aussi
voilà c'est important je me suis épanoui
à travers le sport et c'est important
pour moi de le partager on peut pas
laisser un enfant seul on se doit de le
guider on se doit d'être à côté pour
construire son avenir et en l'occurrence
ici pour essayer d'améliorer son
quotidien et l'accompagné pourquoi pas
dans sa thérapie ici grâce aux pièces
jaunes plusieurs opérations de
rénovation ont été menées dans le
service pédiatrique à la décoration de
dix chambres pour les nourrissons par
exemple a été financé une décoration
avec de nouveaux meubles et surtout des
couleurs ils vont pas dire c'est joli
ici c'est mais c'est dans le
comportement c'est beaucoup plus même
pour les parents d'arriver dans un
endroit
il ya de la lumière ou ya des motifs
agréable
c'est pas du tout pareil qu'un
environnement où c'est tout blanc où
c'est plus stressant donc ça ça aide en
fait
dans la dynamique du service catherine
gaud league souhaiterait une aide
financière pour agrémenter les salles
pour adolescents ce qui ne laisse pas
bernadette chirac est différente nous
allons donner
une impulsion à la construction de
structures pour les adolescents vous
savez que nous avons construit à paris
la maison de solenn est en face du val
de grâce où le var de port royal
et qui dont je suis très fier et nous
avons décidé
de construire une maison de solenn par
département
l'opération pièces jaunes existe depuis
1990 elle se déroule jusqu'au 16 février
859 tirelire sont placés dans dix sept
mille bureaux de poste à travers la
france